it's time for cruise news hop on our
back and we'll take you for a good news
piggyback ride and with me at the desk
is my main newsman rusty ross matthews
that's right everybody hi hi drew
oh
hello color i thought i had some of the
brightest colors in the room until i
found out and saw you man with your hot
pink
vinyl trench coat i already saw her
beautiful i asked her if i could have
the jacket don't you find like in the
middle of winter it's best to wear a
bright color it's just like sorry mother
nature but i'm a win today and you are
winning miss barrymore in that dress
hello hi mother nature i'm gonna win
today i love that that's going to be my
wardrobe north star from now on all
right first step in the headlines this
one's fun online dating is just never
easy for anyone as you all well know i
certainly know apparently it isn't for
zac efron either
buzzfeed reports that zach got on tinder
a few years back and said he never even
got a swipe right oh well
i know i'm like come on and it's not
just him
shaq says that he struck out too you've
got a zack in a shack and they both
struck out and some celebs have had luck
online though simone biles met her
current boyfriend jonathan owen
they're so cool dating app reya oh yeah
yeah that's a big one um i mean i think
my only guess is that what people
thought it wasn't really him yeah that's
it i do buy that people didn't believe
it was really zac efron because can you
imagine not swiping bro i mean my finger
would be bloody from like swiping no i
mean i'm taking but before before i was
in a relationship if i was engaged i
tried online dating once and i this is a
true story i've never told you this
before i was just gonna say ross this is
such fresh meat i can't take it what are
you about to tell this is a true story i
got on one of the apps i don't want to
say which one but i got on and about
four hours later i got a notification
we've removed you for impersonating a
famous person
and i actually wrote back to customer
service i said well for starters thank
you and
number two if i was going to impersonate
a famous person do you think i would
choose ross matthews no i would choose
zac efron hello
so i really think people just looked and
thought yeah right you're catfishing me
bye-bye first of all i would pick you
any day of the week oh you are the best
catch
in the world i'd hook you up like
nobody's business but you're right if
you were going to fake it zac efron
seems like a smart way to go yeah let me
just say i've seen my abs and i've seen
zac efron's abs
yours are better
next up a new study from the uk looked
at the tv watching habits of couples do
you guys watch tv with your partner if
you're lucky to be with somebody it's
like one of my favorite times of the day
oh listen to this the independent
reports that at least a third of couples
spent a total
add it all up of 43 days per year
watching television
i know that i spend at least 90 days a
year watching 90 day fiance that is true
well here's a sad stat listen to this
only four percent of couples say they
snuggle while they watch tv
lame i mean that's the whole point it's
like two people one blanket you don't
have anything in a pod exactly
you must cuddle when you're watching tv
and here's a bombshell 58 of people say
they watch stuff they hate
just because their partner loves it
yeah i don't i don't i don't do that
okay i this speaks to me although it is
not my
love partner in our romantic sure
i have two young girls and the amount of
stuff i have had to sit through
oh god kid stuff
well when i want to watch like football
or something well he just watches
something on his eye like his phone or
netflix on his laptop but we're still
next to each other i don't like the like
you go in that room i'll be in this room
thing we can say hello
i can do the separate rooms oh really oh
yeah absolutely
[Music]
you